It is wild how deeply invested so many people are into
the life of Hannah from Ballerina Farms.
And usually
when we talk about
people being obsessed with a celebrity or an influencer,
we talk about the kind of people that, like,
want to become like them,
that will buy everything that they're selling
and are just obsessed in that way.
But the people who are obsessed in a negative way
and obsessed with, like,
picking apart their lives,
they are just as weird.
So case in point,
I've had quite a few people comment
and let me know that Hannah is running a business page,
like, she has employees
and she is a business,
and they're acting like this is,
like, big news,
like they didn't know this.
But the rest of us are sitting over here like,
yeah, and. And, like,
go on. Of course
it's curated.
She's running a business.
She has millions of followers.
Anybody who has that many followers
is running a business.
And a lot of people have said things like,
well, if I had that much money,
I could do that, too.
Or if I, you know,
married this person,
I would be in that situation, too.
And that is called a cope.
It's a way for people to make themselves feel better
when they are feeling inferior to somebody else. So
I have all these people trying to tell me these copes
and trying to, like,
make me believe them.
But in My head.
I'm just thinking.
I think a lot of other women are thinking like,
we didn't feel inferior in the first place.
She could have $100 million that she's not disclosing.
She could have $10 billion that she's not disclosing.
She could secretly be married to Elon Musk
and not tell us about it,
and we still wouldn't feel inferior.
Just do what the rest of us do.
We follow the accounts that we think are interesting,
and we don't follow the ones that aren't interesting.
It's not that deep.